Hello and welcome to Rawkode live. I am
your host Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
Second State. We're gonna be playing with a
combination of functions as a service, Rust, Node
JS,
and some random other bits and pieces thrown
in together. Joining me today, we have Tim
McCallum from Second State Project. Hey, Tim. How
are you doing?
Fantastic. Thank you. Thanks for having me. No.
My pleasure. I I always love it when
I get to play with WebAssembly. So I'm
really excited to kinda kick the tires on
Second State and see what we can do
with today.
Perfect. Should we start by you giving us
a small introduction into yourself and then we'll
talk about Second State in a little bit
more detail.
Yeah. Sure. So developer
for Second State, we have developers
all around the world, in China, Taiwan, The
States.
At the moment, we're working on a a
variety of different projects,
some blockchain, some web assembly,
very much at the, virtual machine level and
the blockchain VM,
work that we've done in the past ties
in really nicely with the WebAssembly VM work.
And last
year, Michael and I, we went over to
the first, WebAssembly summit,
Google headquarters there in Silicon Valley. So that
was really interesting, really great. And,
since then, we've just come back and just
been powering on,
developing a whole bunch of different, software
applications and tooling and tool chains and,
really,
taking it, to the server side as well.
So
working, with WebAssembly on the server side and
creating a function as a service
for the open web. So, like, a cloud
agnostic
function as a service that anybody can call
just over the web using secure HTTP
requests, and that means
so compiling and launching code as well as
executing it, deleting it, updating it, lock hot
swapping it, live in production.
Probably touching it, fairly soon, but
the WebAssembly VM is obviously a sandbox. You
know, it's got some advantages
that it works in a sandbox environment, so
it's safe to run untrusted code, etcetera, but
also has some interesting nuances like it's stateless.
There's no storage,
doesn't have strings, you know, like the four
data types. It's basically integers and things like
that. So we've worked really hard to try
and bring together a whole ecosystem.
And
I'm essentially part of the
the open API,
which is a function as a service, which
we could have a a good look at
today, that'd be that'd be really cool.
Alright. Excellent.
What do you think some of the
what are the main use cases for someone
who would be wanting to adopt Second State?
What what problems would they be trying to
solve?
So probably the the one, that would relate
to the work I do is
traditionally,
you have, you want to build a web
application or a website, something with a little
bit of functionality.
You'd essentially have to go through and create
the LAMP stack, you know. So you've got
the the Linux and Apache and PHP and
you'd have MySQL and then you've got all
these
issues around,
you know, setting up the database,
all the security aspects of that, doing all
your IP tables on the survey, installing the
server software.
And in any institution, you're essentially running,
you know, like you've got a security team
and those guys are doing all of the
work to secure the network and to
maintain all the firewalls and the servers and
things like that. And what we do is
we take away all of that,
and
we just offer a function as a service,
but not in a proprietary cloud environment
where you have, like, this proprietary, you username
and login and dashboards or any sort of
user authentication access control, all those sorts of
things. We throw all that out the window,
and we just give you a
an API endpoint, essentially like a rest RESTful
API.
So you can stand up a website in
five minutes, like, highly functional, you know, doing
things like, facial recognition, image classification.
Your previous videos there where you did the
anagram solver and things, I've turned that into
an API in a few minutes and deployed
that.
The
this jam stack, I don't know if you've
talked about that a fair bit, but so
the Java API and markup,
that's a really cool framework. So, essentially, the
problem we're solving is we're just saying you
can just use the JAMstack. So you can
have some HTML,
maybe one JavaScript function,
and you call one of the APIs,
and you're off to the races. You've got
a a fully functioning
web application on the open web with no
infrastructure. So it's like a zero infrastructure. You
can even open it statically on your PC,
and you just, you know, say you we
might do this a bit later.
You know, you click a button that files
off a JavaScript function that calls an API
and returns a result, And you can just
do that all even if it's just statically
on your system. So there's no servers, there's
no hosting, there's no security, no databases, all
that stuff. It's all by the by.
Nice. Alright. Let's tackle a couple of comments.
So first, we gotta
wash hands thumbs up. Thanks, Miley.
Pignesh is saying what is Second State really?
I I think we just covered that hopefully.
And we're about to get hands on with
it, so you'll see it in action and
hopefully that will answer any of those other
questions that you have. But feel free to
add more comments if you need. And hello
from Cube Daily. Hey, Cube.
So
can we think of Second State as
a,
you know, you said there's no infrastructure, I
just need to write my functions that gets
compared to Wasm and then I deploy them
to second state essentially like a like, you
know, if I were writing a JavaScript application,
I may throw it to Netlify or to
Versal second state is that but for WebAssembly.
It's my understanding there. Correct. Awesome.
That's right. So the the the function execution
is done on a a standalone
VM, a WebAssembly VM. So Second State
itself
is much broader. The the company Second State
Inc, do a lot of blockchain work. You
see on the website there, which you'd probably
pop over and visit in a sec. Yep.
We have a lot of affiliations with some
some large projects in the blockchain space.
So
there's a fair bit to go through on
the site there. What what I'm mainly, working
on at the moment, is the function as
a service, which is the serverless tab up
there. And, if you click on the blockchain
tab or the other tabs, you'll see the
other projects that we're working on. We're we're
going full steam ahead in in a lot
of directions. So
probably too much to cover in in one
call, but we can certainly look at the
function as a service,
the serverless stuff today. But, yeah, a lot
of work in the VM space,
machine learning AI,
the building blockchain VM for other really high
profile projects.
And it's all open source? There's no proprietary
bits, or is it a mix? Yeah.
Yeah. Every free and open source, the GitHub
repository is just full of all of our
work from the developers in China, Taiwan, America,
Australia.
Yeah. Nice.
Well, let's kick the tires on this then.
Let's see if we can get some functions
deployed.
Is the best place to start clicking on
serverless
and then get started tomorrow? Yeah. I guess
the
yeah. Maybe just suggest a couple of things.
If we just primarily look at the function
as a service stuff today, if you have
a, like, your code editor, if we just
open up like a blank page,
I just recommend that whilst we work through
this, we'll just use that as like a
like a chalkboard to just
paste some text in so we can come
back to it. And I'll show you how
when we launch code, it gives you, like,
an ID, which you then use that ID
to call the code and things like that.
So we just have, a blank
sketch pad, if you will.
I'll send you through a link, which is
the Rawkode livestream links. There's a API
there. If you just click on that API
docs, we might start there.
That's okay with you. Sort of jump straight
in and
Yep. So this repository is just on github.com/tpmccallum.
The link will be in the description afterwards,
but feel free to check it out at
your own leisure.
And here we have
so
this is like the open API generated
document? Yeah. Yeah.
So just recently
entered this
into the Postman API hack, and the name
I came up with was Jampack because we
just talked about the JavaScript API and markup.
And this really is
jam packed. You can do everything with this.
So you can essentially write Rust source code,
compile it to WebAssembly, and launch it, and
then call it. So your application can be
as wild as what you can come up
with essentially,
and we can do a bit of that
today.
So if we scroll down here,
this gives you a bit of an intro
into
it's like an overview. But if we just
jump straight into the,
API calls here,
the first one there that get request,
is, yeah, that guy there, if we just
on the right, you can see the curl
command. So if you paste that into your
terminal and hit enter,
if that's okay with you, like we just
yeah. Is that my computer infected
with some crazy Watson virus?
I was a bit too trusting there, I
think, with that curl command. So these are
all so we're just doing secure HTTP requests.
So those are all of the
Wasm IDs that are in the system. So
when we deploy one, it sends you back
an ID.
And so
if you go down a little bit further,
we've got the the next one there. Oh,
actually, go down a a couple. When you
deploy
a
an executable,
you can actually
get back a
Wasm SHA two fifty six hash.
So if we paste the two fifty six
hash filter by
into the terminal
so it's Oh, no. I think I just
need to Oh, no. That's
we escaped the,
I think we escaped the square brackets with
a backslash. I think that
would resolve that.
Yeah. I think that's cool.
So what that's doing is returning you a
hash of the executable code that you deployed.
And this is good because,
say, you're using somebody else's like, say, do
a Celsius to Fahrenheit conversion or something like
that, and I just wanna share that with
the world. If I know that the SHA
two fifty six is that, then my I
can programmatically check that either before and after
a call. So if anybody changes like, if
the owner of the executable code changes the
any part of the code, then it will
create a completely different hash, and then I
will know, oh, hang on. I'm not actually
calling the function I intended. Now it's something
different. So we cover
that off in a bit.
So does that mean if I deploy
if I
deploy a function on Second State, it's publicly
available for for for everybody?
Correct.
And you can also, when you deploy it,
make it only available to you exclusively. So
100% private by just putting in a
in the header.
You just it'll it'll create a usage key.
And if you don't have that key, then
you can't use it or see it or
anything like that. So and the the feature
of this is if you go if you
make it public actually, we can do this
if you want. Yeah. Let's do it. We'll
launch one. Yeah. Cool. Okay. So let's do
let's do a hello world.
So if we head on over to,
probably back to that GitHub file
that I sent you, if you go to
demos,
let's just click on any one of those
oh, just hang on a sec. I'll just
sorry. If you just go to GitHub dot
com forward slash
second hyphen state.
Github dot com.
Second
state. Yep.
Second-state.
Yeah. And then go just scroll down and
click on the it's Wasm Learning. So just
in the middle there, Wasm Learning.
Yep. And then if you look down there,
there's a folder called f, double a, s,
function as a service. If you click on
that guy.
Yep.
And we might just do
hello.
So this is essentially just a hello world
example.
Yep. And if we scroll down there, you
have Rust installed already. Right?
I do. Yes. Okay. So if you just
scroll up a tiny bit,
there is a little message that says that
you install Rust and SSVM up. So if
you click on that SSVM up link, we'll
just quickly go ahead and install that. This
is a tool chain essentially for the Second
State
function as a service. So, it's just that,
yeah, that bottom guy there. If you paste
that in minus the dollar sign at the
start, that will
automatically install for you.
Piping to our shell, live on the stream.
I get into trouble for that all the
time by my audience.
VM up.
Alright.
Okay.
And so what we do is
if we go and
get clone the Wasm learning repo
onto your system, then we'll have access to
all of those
demos.
Yep. That's it.
Alright.
Let's refresh.
Not done yet. Oh, no. It's quite big.
Give it a second. Okay.
Almost there.
Got a yield from Jared. Hey.
Welcome to an introduction to Second State.
Alright. I think we're almost there. So we've
got fast and we're going into hello. This
is a Rust project with. Yep. Yep.
Hello, world. Right. It's just hello, world. Yeah.
So we could kick off with this. So
if you go to your terminal and go
into that hello directory.
Yep.
Yep. And
once you're in there, if you just type
SSVM
up
as one word and then
build, so space build. Yep.
That will
get that ready for you.
So So this is gonna do a
Rust compilation of the project with a target
of Wasm. There's nothing magic about that at
the moment. Right? And then the SSV Yeah.
Correct. Is that uploading it to the second
state?
No. It's just compiling it ready for you.
Yeah.
Do
we need a rest up at target wasn't
32 VASI?
No.
No. This will this will do it.
Okay. Let's see what the error was. That.
Oh, I don't have a CC compiler.
Okay.
Let's install GCC.
Let's hope Homebrew is feeling quick today, which
it rarely ever is.
I'm sure there's a know what's going on.
Have you got
in your
home directory, have you got a target set
in your cargo dot conf file?
I think that might be it. It's actually
trying to use
because you might have done you might have
compiled some WebAssembly on the system already or
something?
Can't remember how to check that, is it?
Okay.
So that's a tool chain.
Target list.
There's a whole bunch.
Okay. So you said this as target set
of my cargo right now. Is there a
way I can just get rid of that?
Yeah. I'll just have a look.
See if I can remember how to do
this.
So I have compiled WebAssembly before.
Is that potentially
Yeah. I think you've got a
you've got one set there
to
to use that other target, whereas we're just
we're doing this through SSVM up.
Let's see. What can I do?
Yep.
Should I just remove these?
Remove.
Was it 32 of Azure?
Yeah. The other two aren't installed. Let's see
if that helps.
Yeah.
It says no download in that target.
Mhmm. Oh,
no. Oh, wait. Invalid active developer path.
Oh.
That's that weird x code thing, isn't it?
Ugh. Okay.
Okay.
See, it's it's always my oh, one hour
thirty minutes. That better speed up.
Let's set and watch it.
Yeah.
Okay. It's it's it's going quick. I think
we should be okay.
I actually did my max always popping up
asking me to install updates and I let
it I let it do it last night
and I'm assuming that's just x
code just needs that little nudge now. So
Okay. Sure.
So it's quite late for you. Right? You're
in Australia?
Yeah. Yeah. Well, it'd be midnight soon.
This
should take us up to midnight. Yeah. Well,
thank you for
staying up late and and joining me.
No. It's a pleasure. Yeah. I think it's
it.
Drink coffee and eat dark chocolate this light,
so it's a bit of treat.
Yeah. I've been trying to my coffee consumption
is through the roof, but I've been trying
to get better by switching to decaf.
And the taste is well, decaf after 2PM.
And I think the taste is alright, but
I think mentally, I know that it's decaf,
so I just clutch it a little bit.
Yeah.
Yeah. I want the caffeine.
Mac is always wildly inaccurate with its
time frames as well, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah.
It grows.
Seems to have settled on four minutes. So
why don't we take a look at some
of these other examples for the time being?
Yeah. Sure. Sure.
So see those in fact, I'm gonna throw
something wild out. When we ran that curl
command, we got a list of a whole
bunch of Wazee IDs. Can can we Yeah.
Run one of them? Can we use one
of these functions? Yeah. We absolutely can. So
let's do
oh, actually, I'll tell you what I'll do
real quick.
We'll we'll sort of jump to the front
end, because we're we're compiling stuff now and
then pushing it in. So let's actually have
a look at what it would look like.
So if you go back to that GitHub
page,
there'll be
some demos.
So there's the demos there like the
image processing is probably a good one to
to start looking at just to explain like
this holistically.
And I'll just show you one other thing
too. If you go back to the,
GitHub page again, there's a logs section.
What did I put it in there somewhere?
So look.
Right here. This one. Right? Log.
Yeah. Yeah. So it's it's that's not HTTPS.
It's only HTTP. Oh, you've got it. Okay.
Cool. So this will essentially,
I've created a, like, a forward facing log.
So when you run,
it'll actually
give you the output of the execution from
the server, but it's pumping it out into
your browser. So you've got some indication of
what's going on. So what we can do
is you can just refer back to that
whenever you feel like it. If we go
to the
the demo there
This just wants me to upload an image
and then I can do some weird modifications
with it. Yeah. So I've got an example
of an image there. If you just right
click open new tab of that,
that example link.
Yep. And then just save that to your
desktop or wherever, and we can use that
guy.
Alright. So we select the Open browse.
Select that. Cowboy.
Yeah. That's
it. Alright. So we can So if you
click, like
any any of those buttons will be fine.
Yeah.
That's sweet. And if you have a if
you have a look at the log file
there that we've got open, you'll see that
when that executes.
It calls,
WASM ID 273.
And
so, basically, if you just click any of
those buttons, it will just keep calling
and doing, the image processing.
Okay.
Yeah.
So we can we can go have a
look. Actually, if you just right click and
view source, because that's like a a really
simple page.
So
what we've got is a JavaScript function up
the top there. If you see that, I
think it's called call service.
And so this is the the j in
the Jamstack. So all we're doing is we're
calling,
the URL there, rpc.ssvm.second
state. That's where we're actually you know, the
call command before that we're actually just using
that same that's the endpoint.
And so what we're doing here is
we're saying
we've got a multipart form data, and we're
gonna run a function at that wasm ID
of x.
And the function name is called flip or
rotate or whatever.
And this particular one on the end is
slash bytes because we're we're dealing
exclusively
in just in raw bytes here. So we're
sending an image through
to the
to the endpoint, and it's processing it using
the Rust, which is compiled to WebAssembly, and
then it's sending it back as bytes. And
then the the browser's rendering
those bytes as an image. So we're just
running it in its native,
image as
as bytes. And so that's the j. That
that that's the only JavaScript, essentially. And if
you scroll down to the buttons,
I've just made a bunch of different buttons
there.
And each button, obviously, has got a different
name, you know, flip, rotate, whatever. And
so when we click on that, they're all
calling call service, but they're just passing in
the appropriate Wasm ID. So to to go
back to your thing before, like, what if
we called one of those that they're all
calling the relevant Wasm IDs. So, obviously, those
are all public at the moment.
And if you wanted to have your own
custom
Wasm anything, you could deploy it and make
it private.
So
Very cool. I I I like that. I
mean, there was this idea. I don't know
if you're familiar with it. I think it
was, like, ten years ago where Google tried
to launch something called web intents,
which was this idea that you could deploy
functions to the web and they would reveal
their intent like like similar to Android does
it. So you say, hey, this function is
available at this URL and it satisfies an
intent called crop image. And it exposes an
API that anyone can call and then your
your application can just say, hey, I wanna
resize an image and it would find the
intent from the system and this
feels like this could be a really important
part of actually making that a real thing
like where the same state VM and and
the hosting provider infrastructure
and functions. Yeah. Really cool way to connect
the dots there. So I like this. Yeah.
Let's see if we've at least satisfied this
as well just now.
Well that looks a bit better, it's actually
compiling. That looks a bit better.
Now we just have to deal with cargo
being the slowest compiler in the world. Rusty
being the slowest compiler in the world.
But, yeah, that's very cool. I like this.
And it's really the fact that it's exposed
over just a really basic issue to p
rest style or RPC API Yeah. Makes it
really convenient and easy to integrate into my
application as well. I love that that is
Super easy. Yeah. So, you know, you can,
if
you go back to when
phones came out, you know, and we had,
like, programming the web and apps and things
like that, I think
creating apps
is is a really difficult framework to work
with. You got all these different languages and
frameworks, and then you've got two different phone
companies. You have to, like, build an app
for each one. And then if you have
an update, you have to,
you know, basically tell the people, oh, that
the app's been updated, and they have to
pull an update onto their phone. It's just
to me, that's it's super clunky.
This is just using the web as the
web is intended. So if we have one
of these WASM IDs, you can even hot
swap. So if you wanna do an update
because, know, obviously, we're doing image processing here,
but it could be literally anything. It could
be accounting packages or,
you know, IoT stuff or whatever. Say you
wanna you change your business rules or what
have you and you wanna do an update,
you just recompile your WASM. You don't relaunch
it, you just do a put request. So
it's the same endpoints as RESTful.
And when you do the put request, it'll
update the new executable code. And then when
that function
executes, it now does the new thing. But
the user's oblivious. They don't need to know
it. It just does what it's supposed to
do. Now, obviously, from an application point of
view, you've got that hash. So if there
was a security issue where you didn't wanna
run a hash that you didn't know, that's
fine. So it's like an inbuilt security mechanism.
But at the end of the day, you
can create an app in a few minutes
just using HTML and JavaScript. And Yeah.
Yeah. It's it's super clean. It's all open
free
on the web. Yeah. There's no sort of
proprietary
roadblock.
Yeah. So I've got I've got two questions,
and there's one from Jared in the chat
that'll pop up in just a minute. Sure.
So firstly, can can
anyone override what the function does as an
ID? Could I could I replace ID 372
just now?
You can if you have the if you're
the owner, but you can't if you're not
the owner. So I guess if
if that's built, let's go ahead and
build it and and launch it, and then
I'll show you how that works. It's it's
really straightforward how this works. It's super simple.
Okay. So it looks like it's built okay.
Alright. Cool. Okay. So in the p k
g folder, if you just do an l
s on the p k g folder, you'll
see that there's a hello lib v g
w w m. Now,
probably the best way to do this is
to go back to the,
instructions,
so that read me file where we were
before for the hello,
and
it'll show you how to deploy it.
So, yeah, just back to that GitHub page
with the hello.
Yep. And so there is a
so what we're doing here is we're doing
a post request, and we're sending it to
that
RPC.
And so that's all prefilled, actually. If you
paste it in, that'll work because it knows
that's a hello underscore lib underscore b g.
You send that off.
Yep.
And I get an ID back.
Cool. So if you grab all of that,
that's just a JSON response. If you just
take that remember we talked about having a
blank like a a whiteboard?
We just let's just post that into your
blank file
and for for future reference.
Yep. Yep.
And so the WASM ID now is 327
for the hello, and there's your your hash.
And there's a bunch of other information, but
let's not worry about that for now. Oh,
actually, just if you could predify that or
just scroll to the right, we'll have a
look at the SSVM admin key.
Yep.
Let's just see if this is admin dot
j s.
Ew. It didn't make it.
Oh, that's okay. That's okay. Alright. I'll just
go over now.
Not sure why
Yeah. So we'll just have a look at
the SSVM usage key. You'll see that that's
zeroed out,
and that means that anybody can use it.
And
so the
admin key, which is the next one coming
along,
which is sent back.
Yep.
Yep. The admin key is what you would
use in the headers if you wanted to
change something, like,
do a put
and and update the code. So
couple of things we could do. We could
one,
we could hack the hello and say Rawkode
says hello or something and then redeploy it
at the same WASM ID and then see
the sha 256 change. Would shall we do
that real quick?
Yeah.
Okay. Okay. So we're gonna modify this. We
want it to say
Yeah.
Hello
from Rawkode
live.
And then SSVM
build.
Yep.
And then I I just have the same
curl command. I need to pass in my
ID. So
yep. So what we do now, if we
go to the that API, that Jamstack API
thing I sent through That's probably oh, actually,
there might be an example in here
to
do a put instead of a post.
Yeah. Maybe just
yeah. Maybe just head over to the Jamstack
API.
Yep.
Yep. And
it's probably the first put there.
Go on. Up update your put. There we
go.
Yeah. So there we go. So obviously, we
need to tweak that a little bit. So
maybe just put that in your blank file
so we can oh, wherever you want. Yep.
So what we're doing is
the
WASM ID needs to be correct. Yep. And
then so application
octet stream, that's cool. We need to whack
the admin key in there, so that gives
us the power to do this.
I thought nobody watching the stream has updated
it already.
Good point.
Alright. And then we just update We'll we'll
delete it when we're finished. And then obviously,
the correct yeah. It wasn't far.
I'll leave BG.
Yeah.
Pop that in. I think that's all good.
Oh,
that should be package.
Oh, yeah. Package. Yeah.
Ta da.
Yep. So if you grab that and just
pop that in the blank file, so same
OSM ID 327NewSHA256
hash.
Yep.
Yep. Great.
Same admin key, and the usage key will
also be zeroed out. So now if we
run that
by calling it so if we go back
to the,
API
or or actually even to the yeah. To
here is fine because it'll be in this
these instructions. So we wanna do,
yeah, down the bottom there.
And just
tweak the.
Yeah.
Oh, I broke it. I'll try again.
327.
Yeah.
There we go. Rawkode lives. Yeah. Cool. Alright.
So now what we can do is
it's public at the moment, so we wanna
now change our mind and lock it down.
So what we do is we hit a
different endpoint,
if we go back to the API docs.
And so just to reiterate, everything that we
do is all RESTful API. There's no logging
into service whatsoever.
It's all just done through this open web
calls.
So we wanna do a
I'll just have a look on mine. My
screen's a bit bigger here. So if we
go down to
yeah. So down I think it's, the last
put
in that the last put down there. There
is a
API keys
usage key.
Yep. Alright. And if we put yep. Put
the correct WASM ID in there
and then the admin
usage key. So now if you don't have
that key in the headers, it won't work.
And but that's super easy to put that
in the header. So if we wanna call
that again
yep.
Alright.
Yep. Where's the call?
This one? Yeah. And so we wanna add
a header. So dash dash head on a
new line.
What's
the header called?
With
so capital SSVM.
So capital s, capital s,
capital v.
Let me just find it.
Okay. Just one second.
S
s v m underscore usage underscore key. Yep.
That's the one. Yep.
That's the key. And
Equal. Then the value is the
yep.
Oh, because I got the format wrong.
Okay.
There we go. It worked. Okay. Cool. And
so, obviously, we can see that if if
you don't have the key, it's not gonna
let you do it. Now when you create
when you launch the executable the first time,
if you wanted to create a key for
you and you don't have to go through
this process of having it open and then
closing it, you just put, there's a parameter
there which is, like SSVM key and then
you put true.
And then it will be private right from
the get go.
Now you can refresh the key. So say
you do, like, a class or a hackathon
or something and you wanna, like, reset it,
you can run that command we just did,
and it'll generate a new key.
So it doesn't necessarily have to be zeroed
out. It can just create another key. So
you can, like, flush if there's a cohort
of students or something, you can flush that
executable and kick them off and then give
the new
the new cohort the new key and that
sort of thing, or you can just open
it right up and zero it out.
Yeah. Yeah. I changed it.
Yeah. So fairly simple, all just done
with some simple calls. Okay. So that's So
I'm curious then. Right? Like Yep.
And, Jared, I've not forgot your question. I'll
get to it in just ten seconds. But
I've not given you any money. I'm deploying
functions onto the web that I can then
use.
Are there usage
limits before I start having to pay? Are
they Yeah. Like, how how does that work?
So it's
rate limited at the moment, and I've just
set it to some, like, arbitrary, like, a
hundred
requests a minute or something like that.
So what we do
I'll talk I'll talk about this really quickly,
but it's a it's a whole another subject.
But in the in the blockchain space, you
know, there's this notion of gas. Like in
Ethereum,
the the EVM has gas, and so you
wanna perform a transaction. So you give it
some gas, and it goes ahead, and the
miner's mine, and they make a profit and
these sorts of things. We have that same
infrastructure on the WebAssembly VM, we where we
have this notion of gas. So we have
a statistics
section which is implemented
on on here, and it will depending on
what the computation is, it will charge you
a point system. So it's essentially like calculating
compute. And
the gas is a number.
And so
ultimately,
it's a only pay for what you use
system. It's very efficient. So there's no, like,
monthly subscriptions or any sort of costs.
So really brilliant for a a business model
for if you were a web developer and
you wanted to create an app and do
some, like, you know,
image recognition, like plant recognition or something, there's
all these functionality in the Rust that I
can show you later where we do,
some machine learning and AI stuff.
You would pay, like, fractions of a cent
per piece of gas or whatever. But if
no one's using your app, you're not paying
anything. But as soon as they use your
app, then the gas is being calculated. So
there's a there's a good business model you
could take to investors and say,
you know, if the app's
dead for forty eight hours, we're not being
billed.
And so it's different to a cloud provider
where you've got any sort of infrastructure that
you're,
holding on to and paying for when you're
not actually using it. It's strictly a pays
pay for what you use,
architecture.
Yeah. Which is the best way we have
to do it. Yeah. It's it's kind of
the ultimate
way.
Okay. Well, that you mentioned ML there, and
I'll I'll bring in Jared's question, which was
Yeah. Okay. Coral did quite nicely. But he
asked this, you know, is this mainly used
for ML functions?
I guess I would pivot that a little
bit. I mean, do you see people using
this for machine learning workloads?
Yeah.
I'll show you a really cool demo. Go
back to the
the Rawkode links.
I just did this one the other day.
I thought it was
really interesting. If you go up, there's a
OCR
and language translation
demo.
Mhmm.
And I really love this one because
this has actually happened. You know, you go
to a restaurant and so if you save
that as
like, you have a a French restaurant and
you have no idea and the waiter wants
you to order and you you honestly don't
know and so you point at something and
you get something you don't want, It's kinda
funny. And I've been I've been caught in
places
downloading apps and, you know, it's kinda ruining
the experience because you're trying to
do the language translation. I've done this so
many times myself. I'm sat there with my
phone trying to get a picture and get
it and get it to translate for me.
So so we just knocked this up the
other day. This is like a super simple
web app. If we right click in view
source, you'll see that. But, basically, what it's
done is it's taken your image. It's on
one hand, there's a there's a function as
a service endpoint there, which we can see
in the source code. It'll have a WASM
ID, and it has taken the actual letters
out of the image and turned them into
characters. And then there's a second function call
which
converts the language to the language of your
choice.
And so now we have the menu in
plain English.
Very cool. I like that one. Yep. Using
using TensorFlow.
So you can go ahead and train
to do whatever you want. We have, like,
birds and food. And there's one where I
have a video,
and you play the video, and it'll tell
you what the pizza topping is and stuff
like that. So we're just building the infrastructure,
though. These are just, like, prototypes, demos of
what you could use it for to create
your app. And then once you get that
user base, then you pay for what you
use, and it makes your app
attractive too. There's a code for this? Can
we take a look at that? Yeah. Yeah.
Sure. So if we start off by right
click view source, we'll have just have a
look at the the basic bare bones of
the the Jam.
So there's a function there,
I think. Yeah. So it's fairly
straightforward, the JavaScript. So it's just that call
service again,
and it's multipart form data as well. And
if you can see there, we've got the,
Wasm IDE of 284,
and one of the functions is called OCR.
And then the next one below that, a
few lines down, is is also two eighty
four, and it's called translate.
So we can pop over and have a
look at that Rust,
which compiled to WebAssembly and was executed on
the VM. So
I think that is
Yeah.
Let's see.
OCR?
Yeah. I think if you go to OCR,
open up that.
Yeah. That's it. So I've deployed that. I've
done an SSVM up build and deployed that,
and it's come back with that WASM ID.
So that's the the Rust code that will
execute.
Sorry. That will compile to web assembly that'll
ex yeah. The the code jumped there from
hello world to OCR with TensorFlow.
Don't need to understand that, but I like
what it does. So that's cool.
Yep. We have a a question from who's
asking, is there a time out for the
function execution?
No. Not at this moment.
So I could write a function that takes
thirty seconds, five minutes, and that'll run quite
happily in SSVM.
Yeah.
I might I might actually show you something.
One of the powerful things about this and
one of the reasons why we built this
is because
a lot of technology in the hand of
users is moving from powerful machines to smaller
and smaller,
light clients, thin clients, you know, phones, IoT
devices, and that sort of thing. What we've
done is taken
as much of the heavy lifting and all
the processing and
storage and memory and all that stuff, and
we've taken that off
the end user like the client, and we've
moved that across to the Second State infrastructure.
So we've come up with ways that we
can actually stop functions from taking too long.
Essentially, you use the infrastructure as it's intended,
your function should never really take that long.
Like, this is a great example of doing
some really powerful
processing here in fractions of a second essentially.
And so this this is very quick. Where
we find it's slow is if I have
a giant image that I need to upload
from my tiny phone on my very poor
bandwidth
and then process it and then send the
whole that that's actually a bottleneck. But it's
it's not really the system. It's more like
my bandwidth and my device. So I could
show you something really cool.
We can do a remote fetch of an
image. So you know how we're doing the
image manipulation before? Mhmm. What we can do
is
we can hack the so, like, the thumbnail
demo
Mhmm. In the Wasp learning. And instead of
us uploading, you know, you opened it on
your system and then it sent it to
the server and back, what we can do
is we can get it to go and
remote fetch an image
so it's not actually using your bandwidth,
and then it processes it, and then it
sends you back a thumbnail.
So to clarify,
instead of a browse button here, we'd have
a text box Yeah. Pick a URL Exactly.
And then okay.
Yep. Yep. That's right. So if we go
to a different one because that's sort of
like a holistic
demo. If we go to the was I'm
learning and the fast and maybe click there's
an image
thumbnail, like image hyphen thumbnail.
Oh, sorry.
So just in
you have Second State. Yep. So in there.
Yep.
Yep. Yeah. Perfect. Okay. So in the HTML
section of that
folder so we're in the Rust source code
now. If we go into the HTML, open
this guy up. We can go and do
a bit of a hack down below.
So instead of in the form,
instead of the,
where is it? Instead of the the input
typing file, we can change type equals text.
So just switch out the word file for
text. That that would work.
And then
that's probably all we need there.
So then in the Rust where we get
the baits received, right now we're
That that'll be okay. We don't need to
touch that.
Because what we're gonna do is we're gonna
allow the HTML
to tell
Second State, hey. I'm not giving you an
image. I want you to go get it
yourself
and then do stuff to it and don't
use my bandwidth.
So if we, if we go up to
we'd have to do one more thing in
the HTML to make that work. So if
we go up
to
the
form where we actually have the form data
and it says
form data dot append input underscore one,
and then it's passing in the actual file.
What we do is we take away that
and we would exchange
that for something like
document dot get,
you know, dot value or whatever. So we're
actually gonna take the text out of the
the input text and use the text instead
of the file. I'll just
do a quick Google for that.
Okay.
So
it'd be like
document dot get element by ID
value one
oh, input one. Sorry. Yeah. And then, dot
value.
That should be okay.
And then we add that, and then we
append that to the form data.
Yeah.
So I'll just explain something real quick before
we leave this.
When you have
multiple inputs to a function, we know that
in any programming language, you have a function
and then you have that signature. Right? So
you have, like, your arguments.
They have to be in the right order.
And so when you're dealing with something like
this over the web,
if we just say, hey, go get a
bunch of images,
they're all gonna come back at different speeds,
and that's gonna break. So what we do
here is we have this convention in the
Second State infrastructure where we just simply underscore
with a number,
and then it will arrange those in the
right order. So I'm I'm explicitly saying
underscore one, and then I'm giving it that
particular URL.
If we just pop over to the Rust,
just have a a real quick look.
Yep.
Yep. So we we sort of got this
agreement. It's like a convention where the function
is called thumbnail and it takes one argument.
So I'm saying in the HTML
that this is underscore one. If we had
two arguments,
let's say we're watermarking an image and we
had text as well or something, the second
argument would be the text. So the Rust
is expecting that. So what I do in
the HTML is say input underscore two. The
input is irrelevant. It's just the two that
matters. So as long as there's like one,
two, three, four on the end Mhmm. It'll
know, oh, this is the order of the
arguments that need to go and be sent
over to the Rust. Does that make sense?
Yeah. Yeah. You're just you're using like that
incremental IDs convention for the the the Yeah.
Functionality. Right? So does that mean that we
need to change this image to be load
from memory to load from URL or something?
Because that's really No. Not at all. No.
It'll it'll send it to the
function as a service system will go and
do that for us. There's two there's two
ways you can do it. One, you can
if we pop back to the HTML
Mhmm. The one way you can do it
is you can do a, like, a a
post request. And the other way, if you
just put in a URL, it will just
go and fetch that. And so the the
convention for this is if you put see
where it says input underscore one on that
line you're on now? Mhmm.
If you
because the URL equals
yeah. So
if you put
the word fetch underscore
as a prefix
yeah.
Prefix.
Uh-huh.
And and so fetch underscore input underscore one.
Yep. Fetch underscore input underscore. Now what it's
saying is, oh, hey. This isn't just text.
I want you to actually go get this.
And this is our convention that we created.
So now it knows to actually go and
get the image and bring it back as
as raw image data. Yeah. Yeah. I like
that. And that should
work. Now I'll just I'll just get you
an image. If you go back to the
GitHub
with the links
Mhmm.
Maybe just scroll up. I've just,
like, plunked an image up here
in the
there's like a remote image underscore one up
the top there as like a JPEG.
You can click on that.
Click on the download button.
Yep. I think you can actually click on
it because you need the raw
image.
Yeah. And then take that URL. Does that
say raw.github?
Yes.
Yeah. Cool. So that if we paste that
in the text box, it will actually just
go and get the the images raw bytes.
Well, we'll have to deploy this first. Right?
Just have to you'll actually just have to
click save on the HTML
because we're not actually changing the rust at
all.
Oh, so you just want me to open
this HTML file?
Yeah. Just on your desktop. Yeah. So just
save the HTML and just open it on
your locally on your PC. And this is
where the Jamstack thing comes in. You don't
actually have to deploy it. It doesn't have
to be served. It will just work. Yeah.
There is a way to open this in
my browser, isn't there? I'm
sure I've done this before.
I'll just do it from here.
So
what this was the image thumbnail. So open
Yeah. Image thumbnail
HTML
index.
Looks like bitcdn.net
might be a little slow.
There
we go. Oh,
yeah. Cool. So do we have a text
box then? Do we do that? Yep. Oh,
cool. Okay. And then,
hopefully, if you hit that,
Today. Okay.
So what that's done is
your computer has only sent that text. Like,
in the HTTP request, you sent that
text that you've pasted in.
The server side's gone off to GitHub, got
the image, come back, run the thumbnail,
and then just sent you back the thumbnail
only.
Does that make sense? Yeah.
Yeah. I like how
the
JavaScript is just, you know,
a very thin layer on making like an
interface to the actual back end code and
then you've got these conventions of fetch input
which tells Yeah. Second state to, hey. You
wanna go grab this link and send it
into the rest function. So that's Yeah. Yeah.
I quite like that. Very cool. There's other
things,
similar. So you can do, callbacks. So
after
a function executes,
you can put in the header or the
body,
or actually, you can submit a callback into
the system. There's, like, a few different ways
to do everything because we just try to
be as flexible as possible. And what that'll
do is it will execute a function, and
then when the function's finished, it will perform
a callback. So it'll kinda call back on
itself and do more stuff. So, like, you
could maybe now send a text through
a service or, you know, send an email
or something like that, say your image is
ready or what have you.
Can I use that So does that Is
that callback the same
way you would recommend to do, like, functional
composition of chaining more than one second state
function together, or is there another primitive for
that? No. Exactly that. Yeah. That's exactly right.
Yeah. So you'd have we have a convention
with which is SSVM
callback.
And if you put that in the header
and you put in adjacent object, which is
a callback, say, like host port
body,
it'll actually perform that when it'll wait and
say, okay. Do all your stuff. And then
the result comes back, and then it goes,
oh, hang on. I gotta call back, and
then we'll do that on the end and
then send you back the result.
So things like, you know, you might oh,
and there's also a prefetch as well. So
you'll do, like maybe go check a price
of a stock or something and then then
calculate some
change with rust. And then when it's finished,
then maybe the callback converts it from British
pounds to Australian dollars or whatever, and then
it will send that back to you. So
you can do a bunch of different things.
It's sort of like programming the web with
web assemblies.
Alright. I
guess I got an idea then.
I'll
throw this out here. You can get me
away from it if you want. But if
we wanted to show the functional composition,
I believe you've already deployed the anagram finder
to Second State. Is that right? Yeah. Yeah.
So so could we then write a page
like this? It takes a string and put
and we just have a really simple function
that trimmed the space and then forward that
onto the anagram finder and then give us
a list of the potential anagrams.
Yes. So
if we go to the anagram finder,
I think I linked to that on the
GitHub page with the Rawkode links.
Yeah. Which I think I've now
went away from. Let me just pull that
back. I think there's a demo there.
Let
me just close a few of these tabs
actually before I get to Okay. Sure. Well,
like that log one. Let's let's keep that
Yeah. That looks cool. Okay. So
anagram.
Pop you open.
I think that's the article I wrote. Alright.
Okay. Okay. So That's cool. Yeah. There's gonna
be a link at the bottom there somewhere.
Yeah.
I'll put this article in the show notes
as well.
Cool. Thanks.
I was just trying to give examples.
I saw you guys do that. I'm like,
this is brilliant. Because that that would be
a killer app for a
for a trivia night or for a
Oh, yeah. It's safe. So we can see
here a cage ever comes back as trace.
That's right. Yeah. So what happens done there
if I Sorry. Go. I'm just gonna add
some spaces. That should break it. Right? Yeah.
There we go.
Yeah. Spaces at the start, spaces at the
end. We've broken that again, but we actually
want this to work. So I was like,
can we just throw together something that takes
this input
and then chain like the straps the spaces
or non alpha pneumatics, whatever we wanna do
and then pass it on to the Anagram
Pinder.
Yeah. Sure. Yeah. Sure. So we're gonna write
a new Rust function that strips the spaces,
and we deploy that as a new Wasm
ID. We call that. And then when that's
finished, then we're gonna come back and and
then do this.
Yeah. That that we can do that. Yeah.
Okay.
You think we could do that in half
an hour?
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Alright. Okay. Yeah.
Sure. So why don't we just start with
like something I know this is
it seems almost trivial, but let's say I
wanna create a new second state function that
just takes a string, strums the spaces and
spits it back out. What what's the how
do I do that?
So we would
Unless you have any cooler demos, by the
way, if it shows off.
Well,
yes. So basically, what we do is we'd
instead of using the the prewritten
demos that we've got, we just do a
cargo new and,
you know, we we just write a a
Rust function does that. But I do actually
have something really cool to show you. I
don't know how long it will take,
but it's it's super cool
because it solves one of the problems that
WebAssembly
well, it's not a problem, but it's just
like a nuance of WebAssembly and its, persistence.
Because one of the things with WebAssembly is
it executes in a stateless environment. So essentially,
when you call a function, it creates a
new instance of the VM,
the stack,
and it executes.
And then when it's finished, the stack the
the instance of the VM is destroyed, and
it's gone. And so that runs
by itself in a standalone sandbox environment. And
then when it's done, it's
gone forever. And that's a cool safety feature.
And that's the fundamentally what WebAssembly
how it works. But what you don't have
is any persistence. So to write anything useful,
if you're gonna execute a function and then
it just disappears and you and then you
have no persistence, then you can't really write
an application.
So what we created was a storage mechanism
to have persistence, and I'd love to show
you that if that's okay. Yeah. That's really
cool. Yeah. Okay. So
there is a Hello World called I think
it's called Hello Storage.
Let's see.
It is indeed.
So
pop that open.
And so what
this Rust does
do you mind me sort of diving a
bit deep into, like, how we did this?
No. Go for it. Is that cool? Yeah.
Okay. Cool. So
essentially what we did was
the WebAssembly VM is written in c plus
plus and
we're compiling Rust to WebAssembly.
And the
WebAssembly VM only deals in its native,
you know, data types. And one of those
is the I 32. Right?
So what we did was we wrote
a library
in Rust and put it in Crades that
takes any high level Rust
data type like string, structs, doesn't matter,
and it serializes it to I 32.
And then what we're
able to do is have the
WebAssembly VM chew that
and process it because it's it's saying here,
have a bunch of I 30 twos, do
stuff with them. And what we did was
we used the foreign function interface. So between
Rust and c plus plus to actually
say, here's a high level Rust object. I've
converted it to a whole bunch of I
30 twos. Here they all are. I want
you to take those verbatim
and shove them into your memory. And then
what we did was
which which we're basically gonna show here is
you can go and you can go and
fetch them and bring them back. So this
this persists.
But
when a step further, which is even cooler,
instead of just doing that with like, you
know, here's some stuff I want you to
store it and give me back a key,
we're actually using the Rust standard env. So
you program like you would
here,
and
you don't have to actually manage any keys.
It's just if your application like, if your
function endpoint
is deployed at Wasm ID number one
and you put some data into that, it
will just persist. And then when you come
back like a year later and say, give
me back my data, it'll say, there you
go, and just give it straight back to
you. So it's
it's really
it's a fantastic solution to
persistence in
Rust WebAssembly tool chain. Does that make sense?
Am I explaining that? Yeah. Let me try
and summarize that back to you then. So
Sure. I am familiar with the fact that
WebAssembly only speaks
arrays of bytes, alright? So you've got to
run that problem by providing a serialization layer
that actually allows you to work with native
rust objects and types and then SSVM
handles the translation.
What's really cool though is that you're handling
or providing persistence across runs
by just allowing the
programmer to use environment variables.
And then the SSVM is actually gonna say,
oh, there's a new environment variable in this
execution, I'm gonna go store it somewhere. And
then the next time they come back, that
was an ID allows that state to be
then pulled back and from whatever storage back
end has been provided. Again,
by just saying here, there's an environment variable
that's available to you. They don't have to
worry about fails. They don't have to worry
about anything like that. It's just really simple.
Exactly.
Very convenient. Now you don't have worry about
databases or anything like that.
Yeah. That's exactly right. So the
the VM
disappears. It's done. It's gone. When you call
that function again, a new VM comes up.
It's spawned out of nowhere. However, it says,
oh, you've got some data here.
Would you like it? Are those keys mutable
over time? I can modify them in any
execution?
There is two modes. So the top one
is
mutable,
and the bottom examples are immutable.
So the the top we can do it.
Do wanna do you wanna call this?
Yes.
Let's do it. Cool. Yeah. So if we
go to
the
GitHub page, which has the so the the
Wasm learning Hello Storage,
I think there's some, like, cool commands in
there. We can actually we can actually use
this. Yes. So
And we can we can definitely do this
in half an hour. We could, like, we
can do all this. So
Second State while I'm learning.
Yep. So Vignesh has said it's kinda like
Cloudflare workers.
Not actually familiar with Cloudflare workers, to be
honest.
Hello
story. There
we go.
Yeah.
Okay. So let's build it.
Storage
manager.
And then recur less with our ID.
Uh-huh. Oh no, that's a deploy. Okay. Got
it.
Yep.
We'll just give Rusty a couple of couple
of hours of catch up.
Yeah.
So what's actually piloting that storage on the
on the back end?
Rocks DB. Rocks DB. Nice. Yeah.
And we just
transacting
back and forth,
in its native,
binary format. So we're not converting anything to
strings or doing any, like, cumbersome conversions. We
just take the high level thing, we serialize
it and just pump it straight into rocks.
And rocks takes whatever you give it. So
And wanna just just
hands it back. I
wanted to store like a, you know, like
an image, would I have to base encode
that first or is that something that would
be handled?
I know you
just would you
would just send it as raw bytes and
Rawkode would just take it as raw bytes
and just say thanks.
The
if you wanna have a a real quick
look, I I wrote a
piece of software which makes this possible. Sorry.
I'm interrupting now. Maybe.
Back in that Rawkode links, there's a
there's a
down a bit, I think.
Oh, yeah. The serialized, deserialized,
the crate.
So that's
basically what
because you know how you can serialize anything
to, like,
UA.
Yeah. So you just get like a byte
array.
What this does is it takes that byte
array and it turns it into Wasm variables.
So a whole bunch of Wasm variables,
and it will safely
do that back and forth for you. So
that's what that's the, like, the link that
makes this possible
to to the Wasm VM. So the Wasm
VM says, oh, I understand that. Give me
all those I 30 twos I'm gonna do,
put them into RocksDB. Then when they come
back out again, it gives them back. And
then this part of it turns it back
into
the byte array, which then obviously the the
high level
can understand.
Like an image, you know, it says, oh,
I'm an image, you know, once you get
a display that. So there's like this middle
section that which is what you're looking at
now.
Okay.
So let me pop back to
okay. Got another question from Vignesh. What if
the value is larger than a
gigabyte?
It it does up to four gigabytes
at the moment is the the storage limit
is four gig. Yeah.
That's quite generous up to four gig. Yeah.
Yeah. Alright. We got our ID, so now
I can store
a string inside of this. Yeah. So our
ID is 32 Yeah.
So let's store
Hello,
everyone.
And I always like to throw emojis into
the mix here. So let's get a Nice.
Let's put in the meeting. There we go.
My chairman doesn't like it.
Okay.
And 328.
Done.
Cool.
Okay.
Now interestingly correct.
Now that's the mutable,
so if you do another one, it'll give
you back a different key. And now you
can have this whole array of like, if
you're doing this programmatically, you can store all
these in an array and have all this
data that you can call by keys,
and they'll all they'll refresh the keys for
you. And and you can update the data
at a key,
but you can also generate new keys and
things like that. So this is one modality.
And so this isn't using
these
Sorry?
Yep. So I guess I guess I'll I'll
let you do the Alright. Okay. The demo.
Yeah. And then
I actually got the feedback, so that's good.
Nice.
Yep.
And so now if we do
the
standard end, like, if we scroll down, there's
a different demo. I'll just go to it
as well so I can see it.
Storage.
Okay. So we called
store a string, and now I can call
store a string via standard env.
Yeah.
Okay. So if I just
let's say,
change
this one.
Mhmm. What was it? Store a string via
standard. And
Via s t d yeah. Via underscore s
t d underscore e n v. Alright. And
then let's add another emoji. So hello.
And we'll in a wave.
Cool.
And we get a different ID. So this
is our wave theory.
Now you don't need to store that ID.
It just returned it because it could.
That will
always be the same because that's that WASM
ID standard and signature. That's
that's persistent. That's
immutable, essentially. That's Gotcha. Gotcha. Okay. Yeah. You
so you don't have to manage keys is
is essentially what's happening.
Yeah.
You can manage them, but you don't have
to. If you use standard end, but just
it's just there when the VM spawns. It's
your data is just sitting there waiting for
you. So does that mean if I take
off that parameter and just modify the function
call here, do I get that back?
Yeah. I'll just check if that'll work.
Hang on one sec.
So
load a string.
And
yes.
Oh, I beg your pardon. I'm in the
wrong spot. Load a string. Yes. Just do
just do no header either. Just nothing
because you're not actually putting anything in. So
just the post
and then stop after the function name, and
that should be
There we go. Yeah.
And you set that And you can put
anything in there, like a JSON object or
a image or a so that can be
like that function as a services
standard end storage.
You you might wanna pause, Jason. So when
it comes back out, you might wanna, like,
crack it open with cert and say, you
know, give me all the keys or whatever.
It doesn't have to be just text.
It could be a struct. But it's it's
not immutable because I think I just modified
it. But the the key is fixed. That's
what the value is there. I got it.
Okay. That makes sense. Yeah. Yeah. Right. Yeah.
So so you're not managing keys at all.
It just is. It just it's just some
data that you've got access to by standard.
Yeah. Yeah. That makes that makes sense. I
understand that now. So I can use that
function,
use the environment to store it. So whatever
calculation, whatever I need to process, and then
next time I call, I could pull it
out, pull it out as often as I
need.
Excellent. Yeah. Very cool. I like that.
We have another feature as well which
may or may not be useful. It's called
ephemeral storage,
and it's really easy to use. You don't
have to write any rust or do anything.
It's just an endpoint. If we go to
that,
jam packed API,
we can have a quick go of that.
And I'll just explain that in a bit
more detail about why it exists and
because storage is a big, I guess,
you know, given that the the
WebAssembly VM is stateless.
That's
so if we go down to
one of the
put I think it's a put request. I'll
just open mine up so we can see.
There's callbacks.
Ephemeral storage. There we go. Femoral storage. Yeah.
You got that. Okay. So
there is a
I think there might be one up from
that. It might be a post.
I just need to find it. Sorry. I'm
Yep. Post. There you go.
There's a post? Yeah. Okay. Oh, yeah. Cool.
So if you post
the raw data I guess you could just
do that, like, literally paste that in your
cool. So that's giving you back a key.
So if you now take that key and
do the next command
using by passing in that key now this
is just a as a rest endpoint. You're
just sort of putting the key on the
end of the URL. You're not actually doing
anything with complex
headers or bodies or anything.
Yep. What? Cool. And what'll happen if you
do nothing else,
that will disappear in exactly one hour.
But if you do anything to it, like
update it or
touch it or whatever, then it will persist.
So it's just like this additional feature which
is right up at the top of the
API
stack, if you will, and it's for IoT
devices and things like that. Like, if you've
got a temperature sensor that's just recording, like,
once per second, and you you kinda want
it's almost like cache, like buffering.
And then so you're not writing any rust
or doing any sort of low level stuff.
It's just right up at the at the
API
level. And then
you can use those keys to you you
might wanna consolidate a whole bunch of information
over the course of, like, thirty minutes and
then do something with that. It's just to
stop
the developer from having to write Rust to
do everything and deploy things, and it's just
like a high level convenience storage.
Yeah. Because of the fact that you would
we're dealing in a stateless environment, it sort
of makes it a bit trickier to
write an app. So
I I think those last two examples are
there's something really subtle there. Right? But I
wanna kinda call it out is that with
the storage
with the save and storing thing from the
first example and with this ephemeral storage that
has an error. I mean,
I essentially I could use these as a
database, a key value database.
And the latter one function very similar to
something like Redis with a time to live
on that cash value as well.
Even if I don't use any other of
the functions of the service, which is also
really cool, is that I have a key
value Redis available to me on Second State
Virtual Machine
for free Over the the rate limits. Yeah.
And and I guess the only catch is,
like, if you could guess that key, then
you could see the data, but that's gonna
be pretty tricky
because it's open. So
Yeah. I mean, I could I could use
I mean, I didn't have to use
the
I mean, it's a UID. It's like a
secure in a weird way, but it would
be great to start getting Well, I I
guess I guess you hit if someone was
trying to just brute force keys, they'd hit
the right limit. Right? So Well, yeah. I'm
not saying I would use this storage as
my, you know, one password replacement or anything
like that where I just think, oh, my
UUIDs can store my passwords. So Yeah. Yeah.
That that would be a cool hackathon project
actually.
Yeah. Yeah.
Alright. That's really cool. I like that.
I've covered so much. Like I could write
Rust code, compel it to Wasm and store
it and it's always available over an HTTP
endpoint. And then beyond that, you've already got
these pre canned functions which are deployed for
a femoral storage, and I can use persistent
storage.
Are there any guarantees
on the persistent storage for my application? Like,
could I or should I expect that to
disappear
at any point?
It's,
you know, technically,
it's
forever because
the system will run and continue to function,
and
the the information goes through into the RoxyB,
and it will be there when you come
back. That that's the the premise. You know?
That's the
all things being equal, it's
that that that functionality is intended. So yeah.
Okay. Just a random question. Who provides the
compute? Is this sponsored by Second State? Are
you providing
all the compute power here, or is this
where the blockchain comes in and other people
are providing compute? Is this distributed in the
back end? Do wanna give me a little
bit of information on that? So so that's
essentially the next step is to we've come
up with a
plan where
not only is it
feasible for
for us to host this because
we have this the statistics like the gas
and the metering and things like that.
Any app developers who wanna build upon this,
they can also
talk to their investors and say,
you know, I've written a few hundred lines
of Rust. Here's some HTML and some JavaScript.
Here's what it looks like, and here's what
the users would do to convert their menus
to English or whatever whatever usage
use case they have. And then, you know,
what's it gonna cost me? Says the investor.
Well, it'll cost you, you know, 2
per
or, you know, or 0 something cents per
use.
And so,
you know, if the if the application if
the web application users are paying a dollar
for the app or something, then you're gonna
cover those costs. So the the business model
is sound in that. We have a mechanism
to meter and charge in. But that's really
the implementation of that is coming.
We've built out as flexible infrastructure as possible
so that we can do stuff.
And the
machine learning and AI and all the TensorFlow,
and and the Rust components and,
all of that sort of those prototypes are
just trying to demonstrate that
you can build a lot of cool stuff
on this. It's kind of up to your
imagination really as to what you can build.
I've tried to write articles and, you know,
like, anecdote. I'm like, that's cool. I could
do that. That that's easy.
But you could come up with some really
nifty stuff and build it out in, like,
no time, and and it would be fairly
cheap to run. Yeah. There's no doubt that
the WebAssembly VM's
very powerful. Oh, probably the most important thing
I should mention
is
we're not running
just in time compiled
the native WebAssembly
executable that gets uploaded,
we actually
our developers have
written so we actually convert that to a
o t compile, which is why it's so
fast. And there's an article just published,
which I can send you, and and you
can link to that about the benchmarking
between the Second State
WasmVM
and the other runtimes and the other VMs.
And our IoT compiling
component
means that our stack like, our execution is
blisteringly fast. So the the the latency across
the network is really the the biggest thing
that we're seeing.
And the other the other cool part about
this, the SSVM up tool
is basically, it's based on Wasmpec,
but we're not just writing this for, like,
the web or for the for the browser.
We're taking this onto the server side. So
you can do all of this
on the server
as well, like, even in the command line.
So no API, no web. Just if you
have, like, a factory or some sort of
closed
environment where you just want really powerful
execution,
you can just do that
on like, directly on the server by installing
the SSVM on on that machine and and
executing that. We're trying to cover off all
the different areas. This open API is essentially
giving
end users access to the
back end through the open web. But you
can you can run this stuff just straight
out on the on the server if you
want. Like, literally command line and pass in
a big file and
do whatever you want
to it.
Awesome. I mean, there's just so much flexibility
and options to the way I interact, engage
and kind of compose these things together. Like
you you can do a lot with this.
Is Yeah. Is there anything that you wanna
show before we finish up for today? Is
there anything that we've missed that you'd like
to?
I don't think so. I think that's that's
a fairly good
yeah. We've done remote fetching and we've done
storage and yeah. I think that's that's a
good
Yeah. We we've
a lot. I mean, we we had some
Rust code.
We built it. We deployed it. We upgraded
it. We then interacted with it through really
simple HTML with a little bit of JavaScript.
We covered the semantics around how the inputs
with the numbers work. We covered fetching.
There's just so much there. And then at
the state, the ephemeral storage interacting with the
environment. So much good And there for people.
And we covered the, security aspect. So it
can be a private function,
or you can open it up, have it
public, but you can choose to toggle between
those two with just a simple request.
So
that's that's a big part of it, I
think, too, is Yeah.
I think code reuse is interesting because,
you know, the DRIP principle and KISS principle
and all these things that you learn.
We really we really shouldn't have to write,
like, a basic example, like, you know, Fahrenheit
to Celsius or something. That should only probably
exist in one place. Right?
Or any sort of decent
function
that exists. It'd be amazing if instead of
people writing that separately,
if it was in here and someone could
improve on it, they could come and have
a look at the Rust source code, make
a change, improve it, prove that it's more
efficient or whatever, and then
get approval to update it. That was my
idea, and then that's like your superior
function for that purpose in the world. And
and but that's not reality, is it?
I've got a a really cool hack project
for us to maybe work on if we
if we have the time where I I'd
really love to see like, can I add
arbitrary headers to my function deployment, like as
metadata?
To the rust or to the Yeah. So
if I write a function
Yeah. Can I just scrape that to Second
State somehow? Can I like if I wanted
to add an intent header, SSVM
underscore intent, it says resize these images? And
then could I then provide a function which
discovery
via that metadata to actually build out that
intent system on Second State? I think that
would be really
Yeah. Yeah.
Absolutely. We could definitely accommodate that. And I
think it it'd be great if you had
a place where you could go to shop
for functions or functionality and
and then you could, like, rate it. You
know, this is the best
temperature conversion function because of whatever reason. And,
you know, you're sort of, like, building up
a
what would you call it?
What's that restaurant app where you Yelp or
something? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yep. Yep.
That would be brilliant. You can be shopping
for a function. You know? What's what's the
best OCR function? Test it out. Yeah. That
works.
Plug it into your app and then give
it five stars and yeah. I I think
me as a as a developer, right, especially
if I'm leveraging a platform like this, and
I say, oh, I really wish I could
translate this from English to French and I
I shouldn't have to write that again. Other
people have done it, they should expose it
as a translator with languages that they support
and then I just call it and I
can pick what I like or I could
just tell the intent system, hey, I wanna
translate. Don't really care which one you use.
To and like
lots there. Not gonna try
and drag us into a different conversation right
now, I think we should continue this offline
at some point. We do have one more
question from our audience. Fagnes is back again.
Thank you, man for the questions. Keep them
coming. Is the function deployed globally? So, you
know, I'm in Scotland right now. Where where
is this being served from? Because the latency
has been quite good, actually.
Yes. It is deployed globally.
Yes.
And at the moment, we're just running this
from The United States. And so me calling
it from Australia, I generally find it's you
know, when we take talking millisecond execution on
the VM, I I'm finding, a second to
me seems like a long time. But when
I but when I deploy it in Sydney,
it's super fast for me. So it's it's
really the latency. But, yeah, it is global.
Yeah. And
we're setting up another server,
another lot of infrastructure at the moment, which
I'm gonna do, which is inside China. So
that's just doing it on a different platform.
Yeah. So
Awesome.
Alright. Well,
that was really great. I really loved learning
about Second State, and I can see so
much potential and how other people can leverage
it and and use it. And I I
can't wait to kick the tires on it
a little bit more. Do you have any
final thoughts before we finish for today?
No. I'm all good. Alright. I'm good. Thank
you for having us. It's been a pleasure.
It's been really great fun. No. Thank you.
I I know you stayed up really late.
It's getting to what? Probably half eleven at
night for you. So, you know, thank you
for taking the time joining me today, walking
me through this. I had an absolute blast
and we'll chat again Awesome.
Thank you so much. Have a great night.
Okay. Thanks. Bye. Bye.